with each passing iii-v our [ __ ] becomes
more and more of a bigger part of the
scene and of course one of the biggest
players in VR is oculus VR joining me
now founder of oculus Palmer Luckey
Palmer glad to be here thank you for
joining me on the stage thank you for
bringing your little guy here that's
right ah this is now you guys had your
press conference on Thursday you show
this off this is the sort of consumer
form factor you're going to be on next
spring this is almost identical to what
people are going to be getting early
next year we're hoping pre-orders later
this year we're showing off nine games
on the show floor we have about 20
partners that we announced last week
we're gonna be showing more of those as
the year goes on really excited to
finally get this into the hands of a
bunch of different people yeah and
you've got a big booth over here a lot
of people are getting to try it out have
you sorted do you check in with people
when they come out of it for the first
time you try to get some impressions of
how they experience it you know that
happens a lot not so much a TV 3 because
I'm trapped up in our press room and
almost all the press that we've talked
to they've tried virtual reality before
but even though they've tried virtual
reality before a lot of people are
coming out and saying this is a good
stuff and it really is it's a lot
lighter it's a lot more comfortable
we've improved the display is the optics
of the audio it's it's a it's a really
solid complete package yeah so much of
the experience is obviously that
immersion and so having the thing on
your head not like be able to fade to
the background the physical reality of
what you're wearing what's enabling it
you want that to not be the story
exactly and that's different for a lot
of Technology where the story kind of is
the tech and its core functionality we
want the rift to be different than that
it's kind of like a conduit for content
it's transparent ideally you wouldn't
even know you're wearing the rift
obviously you know look at this we're a
long way off from that day yeah you'll
know when you're someone's wearing it
but some day we want to get to the point
where you don't and so we've designed it
to be really comfortable not trying to
make the design really understated yeah
we've used plastic and textile
composites to make it really light and
adaptable to your face we're shipping
with multiple facial interfaces for
different types of faces people who are
going to wear glasses that it fits over
those well all to try and make it so
that you don't remember you're wearing
it now have you sort of when Nintendo
came out the wii they would put a notice
up says like hey maybe you want to take
a break because they realize
that the wii was a much more physical
Devereaux's a different way of
interacting with the game have you guys
thought of any kind of like little pink
notification it's me like I oh it's been
like seven hours maybe need a timeout
hey VR doesn't necessarily have to be a
physical endeavor I mean you don't have
to you know wave your arms around and
stand up and walk around you sure will
be experiences that do that but most of
the games that we're showing our games
that are built around seated use so you
can sit there and play for really long
periods if people want to sit and play
for a long time I mean let him do it
yeah absolutely uh I played for his
either is between 12 and 16 hours in one
sitting one time a people generally do
that but I did I did do it one time I
just beat an entire game straight
through mm-hmm now I during the press
conference last Thursday you guys
announced your sort of partnership with
Microsoft and bringing the controller to
bat packaging it with an xbox one
controller I want to talk about the
other input device you announced then
but first what is it you know what kind
of VR experiences do you think are best
for the for the xbox one controller and
what which ones do you think would
thrive with the other types of input so
the partnership with Microsoft gives us
a few things one is the xbox controller
yeah the others we get to work with them
on Direct X 12 optimizations and
operating system level optimizations
that make virtual reality perform better
and I'll be a lot easier to use so we've
been able to get under the hood with
them and make a lot of improvements that
make it easier to run high performance
virtual reality games on your PC but for
the controller itself people have been
developing virtual reality games over
the last couple of years and people have
developers have proven you can make
really good virtual reality content
using game pads in fact most of the
condo that we're showing today uses
gamepads hahaha and even though people
have a decade's figure out how to make
great gamepad games translated over to
VR has taken time so one of the pieces
of feedback could be got from developers
all the time over the last couple of
years like literally some of these games
have been developer / over two years now
and they were saying look we want every
person to be able to buys the rift to be
able to play our game without being able
without having to buy additional
hardware and a gamepad is not a huge
significant cost it's something we can
do to make our developers more
successful and to make sure that there
is a baseline reference for what a four
is going to have to use but there's a
lot of games that are always going to be
optimal for gamepads uh you know
one-handed controllers are great but
especially what if you're using analog
sticks using one analog stick against
the hand that you're actually bracing
not like trying to move the analog stick
while bracing it with the hand it's
actually moving it it can be fatiguing
to use for really long periods of time
so for a game like a Valkyrie where it's
a space dog fighting game and you've got
multiple analog sticks in a huge array
of buttons that you need to do to
activate different functions a gamepad
is going to be one of the best ways to
control I'd play that yeah and you're
actually seeing that in the like when
the US Army actually uses standard
gamepads to control some of their
military hardware no they don't they
don't do it like they have access to all
kinds of other stuff but the reality is
that people have the muscle memory they
know how to use it most importantly it
has a lot of complex inputs on it then
allow for complex game genres that
require that type of input and it's
interesting to hear you talk about sort
of that controller because you know
controllers as we know them now yeah
years and years of study design have
gone into this but so much of the oculus
design process is doing study and design
in ways and bringing it together in ways
that people have not been used before
because if you know what that's really
one of the things we have to do oculus
is a company that lives and dies by
virtual reality if VR isn't successful
we die whereas for a lot of these other
companies it's kind of a side project so
we have to dump a ton of money into
getting it right ourselves because we
can't afford to fall back yeah so one of
the things that we're showing at the
show is oculus touch which is our new
set of six degree-of-freedom 3d
controllers it allows you to well put
them on and actually have a
representation of your hands in virtual
space but not like connect or something
where it's just tracking you know ghost
ghosty hands we've designed it to
actually be kind of a cross between
traditional inputs and natural inputs so
it has an analog stick on it it has
buttons but as a ring on it so that it's
balanced so that it doesn't feel like
you're waving something around its
balance kind of around your hand you're
able to its able to track your fingers
using a matrix of centers matrix of
sensors that are mounted throughout the
device you can point to things you can
give a thumbs up you can do other things
with your finger or just throw up the
horns you can't do that right now you
can't track your pinkies just yet I
haven't gotten all the way it isn't a
particularly high priority for us a big
tracking is not on the Milice
I know unfortunately okay okay but we've
been showing those off with toy box
which is our internal test bed that
we've been using over the last several
years to develop virtual reality input
and it's not really a game but it's a
multiplayer experience where you can
kind of you could shoot laser guns with
people you can build blocks to play
tetherball I can teleport us between
different worlds kind of like in the
construct in the matrix form or face is
able to take neo to different places we
give a space underwater back to a blank
white room it's it's a pretty cool demo
it's interesting to hear you talk about
multiplayer because I think when a lot
of people see a VR helmet they see it as
an isolating experience because you're
not seeing what's around you if
someone's on the couch that that doesn't
matter but they're a lot but gaming is
inherently social in a lot of ways and
so how sort of how does gaming's social
aspect manifest itself when it comes to
oculus games in a lot of ways virtual
reality can actually be the most social
type of gaming that there possibly is
what's more social than being able to
take a person and make them feel like
they're in a place with another person
without actually going to be in that
place I mean you know there's a lot of
local multiplayer games that work well
because online multiplayer you're
basically limited to disembodied voice
chat you know floating from your friends
head yeah actually hanging out together
is a lot cooler and so virtual reality
is the only tech that can make you
really feel like you're in a virtual
world of someone else and if you look at
the history of virtual reality
especially virtual reality science
fiction things like Snow Crash are ready
player one they don't detect virtual
reality is isolating at all science
fiction as known for decades that VR is
not an isolating technology you don't
read sci-fi books about gamers sitting
alone in their room playing VR games
it's about people being in digital
worlds that exist alongside parallel to
the real world and communicating and
mass whether it's playing games doing
work education those are the types of
things that have always defined virtual
reality we're just starting to get to
the technology to the point where we can
actually make it happen we can make a
virtual social network if you will you
know what the concept of a social
network as it exists today I don't think
is going to translate directly over to
virtual reality it's not obvious that
that's the best way to do things that
might be good for a mobile phone or for
a desktop PC or laptop but when you're
in virtual reality there's so many more
things that you can do and in a way
social game
has turned into a bit of a dirty were
like social gaming means shitty gaming
and social features means useless
features but being in a virtual world of
people is social gaming like it's almost
the definition of it and I think that
it's going to really inspire people to
do a lot of incredible things we're
already seeing that from our developers
and yeah you make great references to
literature that is certainly envisioned
that for years I'd be interesting to see
the oculus reading list of sort of stuff
that has inspired the design processes
in the kind of a long way yeah systems
you're imagining for oculus now I think
one of the things at e3 that we've seen
is you know the oculus other VR is on
display but the big consumer push feels
like it's maybe coming next year you
know anything with you guys coming to
market in the spring and other release
dates not really announced for other
competing hardware I think the question
on a lot of people's life Tony said
first half of next year right our
staffing next year I think that's what
they think that's what Sony's pushing
it's gonna be a busy first half then is
I think one of the questions on
everyone's mind is the R word of mouth
is very powerful but how do you convey
the VR experience how do you sort of
sell someone on VR who can't necessarily
put the helmet on themselves who maybe
doesn't have the opportunity the only
way is for them to try right the only
way I can attempt to depict it and some
people who are familiar with the eye and
we kind of have this advantage other
technology has to like wearable watch
like wearables for example whether it's
fitness bands and watches they've to
convince people this is something they
care about Victoria highs the advantage
of having lots of sci-fi and so a lot of
people have seen the matrix you're like
this is little it's like the matrix kind
of like oh I understand that I get it
and they can imagine it uh-huh but a lot
of people especially you know haven't
seen movies like that who don't care
about those they need to be convinced if
you are something they care about and
that's why we're here with a huge booth
like our booths get bigger and bigger or
not because of vanity it's because we
have to show them to as many people as
possible or more people yeah and that's
why we go to a ton of shows show as many
people as possible once virtual reality
is shipping to people they'll be able to
show their friends I think that's going
to drive a lot of adoption when I can
show you know my ten friends my less
than ten friends for what what virtual
reality is like
they can get excited about it and we're
also pushing to try of ER in retail so
that people who don't have any friends
can also go and check out virtual
reality and see what it's like and some
people are going to want it right away
some people are going to say too
expensive the quality is not where I
want to be but that's okay sure because
the very least once you try VR you
understand the idea well enough that
most people know that there is some
point where it will get cheap enough
small enough comfortable enough full of
contents enough they are gonna want it
if it's not today not next year maybe
the year after that maybe it's 10 years
from now but the little confidence
everybody yeah and I think one of the
really interesting things you know
obviously III is a gaming stage and
there's a lot of wonderful gaming
potential in VR but you know when you
guys talk about VR you talk about
presents and I think people who are
outside of gaming you know the ability
to just put this on and feel presents in
a forest somewhere on the top of a
mountain any any landscape designer can
imagine I think that's one of the most
powerful things that VR can do do you
when you guys are designing it you know
obviously sort of you you're tackling
the key challenges of gaming are you
also trying to envision those
applications for people who just would
want on different kind of experience
that kind of presents some where they
couldn't even imagine definitely I mean
there's two sides of it there's there's
car that recreational side that you're
talking about where it's I just want to
be a place that I'm not and that's novel
on its own but right now the games
industry is dominating VR because it's
the only industry that's equipped with
the tools and the talent to make
immersive real-time 3d worlds and that's
why you're gay murs are really the only
people who are investing in the hardware
that it takes to have really
cutting-edge experiences what's going to
change over time as you start CPR go to
more people you're going to have things
like education being able to take people
to learn about things that they couldn't
possibly whether it's seeing the body on
a much smaller scale than is possible in
real life or taking a field trip to
someplace that either doesn't exist
anymore or you can't afford to travel to
elderly who are frail and trapped in
nursing homes will be able to go places
whether the real places or virtual
places and escape from where they are
using virtual reality and don't even get
me started on business telepresence it
sounds boring but you're here and I'm
here because we've decided there's some
value in all of us
traveling this convention center burning
millions of gallons of fuel yeah and
countless dollars so that we could sit
together on this stage eventually if
you're going to be able to do that in VR
that is a really positive thing to be
able to bring people from the other side
of the world at no cost at no resource
cost that that's going to be something
that's really huge it's pretty
incredible Palmer and I think your
wardrobe choice today is fitting because
hearing you talk about VR and imagining
just the sheer breadth of ways that it
can change so many different sub sectors
of our society kind of feels like
looking up at a field of stars we're
just is bigger and bigger the more you
look at it it's true and like to touch
on another thing is digital
communication in general is pretty
flawed right now like we use skype we
use cell phones we use text messaging
but they're all broken abstract forms of
communication that we've invented around
the limitations of technology not what
we actually want to do and so I feel
like that's also driving a lot of it's
hard to get like sarcasm across in a
text for example it's also really easy
to be extremely aggressive towards
someone when all you're doing is writing
an email just trying to communicate a
fact to you I didn't mean to I didn't
mean it and in a way virtual reality is
a as a potential to be the most human
form of digital communication yet
because it can make you feel like you're
in a place to another person interacting
with them in the same way that you
interact with a person in the real world
that's going to change gaming that's
going to change entertainment that's
going to change a lot of practical
things to amazing technology with
amazing potential Palmer thank you so
much for coming on the stage Brianna me
much appreciated ladies and gentlemen
the future is coming it's going to be
pretty fantastic we'll be back live with
more gamespot coverage of e3